and it's that progress on the vaccine
rollout which is leading many businesses
and
mps on the tory back benches to call for
a wider opening of society
skies helen ann smith's been looking at
the data informing the government
it's the million dollar question when
and how will life return to normal the
government's being a little more careful
about committing to hard dates than it
has been in the past
so what do we know well the prime
minister will announce more in his
roadmap on monday
that's also the day that welsh and
scottish schools will start a phased
return
we now know that care home visiting will
be extended from
the 8th of march and that could also be
the day the english schools start going
back
beyond that it might logically follow
that rules on socializing retail and
hospitality might follow in the coming
months but we just don't know
yet the new government mantra is data
not dates and the data may still advise
caution this is case rates from the
office for national statistics survey
the current rate of decline is striking
look at the steepness of that line
but when we compare it to where we were
in june when the schools last reopened
the rates are still quite high notice
too how those numbers did start to climb
back up once the autumn term got
underway now case rates are an
element that will guide decision making
another key thing will be
vaccinations the program's been rapidly
accelerated
and it's expected to continue to do so
given care home visiting will be one of
the
first steps in a reopening plan this
number will be
likely very important all english care
home residents have been
offered a vaccine and nearly 95 have
received their first dose
but it's a different story when it comes
to care home staff
despite being a priority group less than
70 percent
of english care home staff have had
their first vaccine and there's huge
regional
disparity london there just to over 50
percent
there's a concern that vaccine hesitancy
particularly
among some ethnic minority groups may
partly explain this variation
now matt hancock has previously
indicated that hospitalization rates
will also be a guiding factor so how's
that going well this shows the number of
patients in hospitals
and it's falling again you can see here
but just look at this line that cuts
across the middle
this shows that as of the most recent
data we have there are more people
currently in hospital
than there were at the peak of the
crisis all the way back in april
now this all amounts to a tricky
balancing act for the government
expect any road map to be caveated with
this
a change in data will mean a change in
plants